I'm that filthy
[Applause]
[Music]
I am about to let my seven-year-old
daughter design the tattoo for me are
you ready for this
what is your favorite thing to draw
flowers with my favorite flower
okay lips what I know about tulips is
they continue growing after you cut them
oh she listens that's true over the past
year I started adding tattoos that told
the story of my postpartum experience I
got really sick in my brain after
Delilah was born I had postpartum OCD in
depression it feels like the most
natural thing in the world to have this
girl who was there with me through all
of my depression to throw my next piece
make sure you don't get these like a
list erased parts in the tattoo I'm
really excited to have this drawing of
word on my mom's arms gonna be really
cool okay I'm 1d I love this
I am Zilly and we are here at the Warren
I'm about to tattoo a seven-year-olds
artwork on her mom if the daughter is up
for it she could or rather if the mom is
up for it daughter could help with the
tattoo I could help guide her can't make
any promises for how that part turns out
hi over you
we got there well I give this this is
what I want you to tattoo and that's
really good thank you
yeah I can totally touches we might need
to make it a little smaller we're going
on your forearm I love seeing all those
little lines in there even though this
is clearly the finished product but I
like seeing those behind there would be
okay if I kept them I'll give it this
regeneration and just like are you gonna
lower her how about if I just make it a
little lighter for you where do you
think the petal is like here you're
hoping in the flowers are you at yours
I don't know you started training today
you want to try a new medium today I'm
gonna draw me with a tattoo machine hmm
yeah okay
looking a little phallic it doesn't get
all without you take those off yeah
maybe we'll just skip the petals perfect
[Music]
what do you think Delilah how does it
look
[Music]
so we have Delilah do the first part of
color it's even the noodles come into it
things in me moving really fast and if
you touch it it's gonna poke okay so we
don't want to do that well I'm - really
good yeah ready
and the friend like this color you can
go bigger okay fill mommy pretty good
actually I planned eat a little we did
that low doing like big show I'm filthy
yep fun town you mean I win
for you
[Music]
I find myself closing my eyes when Billy
touch me because it hurts and it still
hurts Wendell I was tattooing but I
can't stop watching her do it just like
maneuvering around corners and [ __ ]
[Music]
another gone if you just did like a
light yellow behind what she did
think we're done
I love it d I can't believe you colored
in this whole touch I love this tattoo I
like Geralyn on your arm like a lot like
my baby you do you think we should get a
tattoo gun and you just tattoo me all
the time oh yeah I ever send this stuff
to take home and just sleep in no time
no but thank you for helping with my
tattoo
[Music]